hi my name is Jonas Cleveland and it's a
real pleasure to have our keynote
speaker here today I know many of you
knew that he was supposed to speak last
year unfortunately he suffered a back
injury wasn't able to be with us but we
have him here today after delayed flight
and a bunch of situations he's here with
us so a very thankful today we have a
distinct pleasure coming from one of the
foremost voices in the black community
in - civil rights movement born in
Detroit Michigan during the during 1958
dr. Dyson struggle struggles in his home
town segregated high school soon found
him the teenage father living off the
welfare system finding purpose and
support in the church
Dyson returned to high school and after
working in maintenance and auto sales to
support his family eventually became an
ordained Baptist minister today dr.
Michael Eric Dyson is a University
professor of sociology at Georgetown
University and holds a PhD in religion
from Princeton University a renowned
public intellectual professor Dyson's
innovative scholarship combining
cultural criticism and biography focuses
on race religion popular culture and
contemporary issues in the black and
african-american community he is the
author of 16 books they're all found in
the intro in the bulletin but Dyson's
15th book released in 2007 know what I
mean is a critical study of hip-hop
music addressing issues ranging in the
music's creative expressions the global
exposure exposure commercialization and
Pilatus elitism of rap music and its
most influential figures his previous
book debating race is a compilation of
previously unpublished conversations
with scholars politicians and public
commentators he's also authored authored
come hell or high water Hurricane
Katrina in the color of disaster his
Bill Cosby writer has the MEK or has the
mad bike middle class lost his mind
Eric the Michael Eric Dyson reader open
mic
however hear me searching for Tupac
Shakur
while I love black women I mean I get
there with you the true Martin Luther
King jr. race rules navigating the car
line between God and gangsta rap making
Malcolm
in the meeting of Malcolm X and
reflecting black Dyson is also named one
of the 100 most influential black
Americans by Eponine magazine a popular
Barack Obama supporter dr. Dyson is
perhaps mostly pot mostly known as a
regular commentator on NPR CNN in the
HBO's Real Time with Bill Maher his a
pleasure and an honor for me to welcome
our keynote speaker dr. Eric Michael
Dyson
thank you so brother so much my brother
for that very gracious introduction
for brother Jonas Cleveland for that
rousing and stimulating invitation to
think about myself not in that way to
president Jared Cohen whose graciousness
and hospitality always warm the heart to
sister Renee and to so many of the other
fine
members of the staff who have been
gracious and hospitable to me and to my
lovely sister who met me at the airport
and had to deal with some silliness but
here we are nonetheless it wasn't my
silliness I just want to be clear about
that as my daddy used to say were you
cutting the food but what an honor to be
here today back again here at this great
institution of learning Carnegie Mellon
a world-class institution of higher
education and I want to thank the
student body president brother it it's
go it's a coup it's for his graciousness
and the brilliance of these students
brother Carlton Reeves and sister Tarun
Hall weren't they extraordinary in their
speaking
was it urban Berliner who wrote those
words I just feel so unnecessary I
didn't have to make this trip here even
though it's good to be here in Tomlin's
shadow there's a guy on the plane
they're white brothers saw a lot of
people taking pictures and getting
autographs he says are you a Steeler I
said yes sir Jerome Bettis so get on the
bus we both from Detroit don't make no
difference
y'all feelin pretty good here in
Pittsburgh trying to take it to that old
man to Kurt Warner but he's old old
people get desperate so be careful of
his wily skills especially old people
who have been counted out and come back
that's the beautiful thing 38 ain't old
in the real world but in the world of
sports it is 38 year old in sports
you're a young person if you're an
executive so it depends on your
perspective but what an honor to be here
I'm so sorry I rarely rarely cancel I
have to be really down on my back and I
literally was last year I would have
come here like that but I would have
scared you to death so I'm honored to be
here today back again and I counted the
signal honor that your great president
and all of the wonderful staff who
invited me here have opened their arms
to me again now I want to talk about as
the program mentions it I won't thank
sister Ashley Burrow's too for that
great leading us in all three verses
of lift every voice and saying makes you
think about it doesn't it all those
verses right I want to talk about this
great subject King Obama and the
American dream because as we stand
poised tomorrow for the inauguration of
the 44th President of the United States
that's just the mind-blowing thing in
its own right we could meditate on that
alone it's only been 44 men who have
occupied the Oval Office that's a pretty
remarkable fellowship and as yet
fraternity that those distinguished men
have belonged to Hillary Clinton almost
made it a sorority and even though I
supported my man Barack Obama above a
huge Hillary Clinton love her a lot of
people hating on Hillary a lot of it was
sheer sexist sheer sexism they invented
that she was mean and nasty and had
horns and was the devil and you talked
to her and engage with her she's so warm
and gracious and highly intelligent and
and that's why she got the plum rolled
she got a plane and now she can go on to
the Middle East and try to work that out
but I supported Barack Obama and the
fact that he is the 44th President of
the United States is something one can
scarcely grasp usually when you mention
a black man in 44 it's a high caliber
pistol
when I was a young boy I'm 50 now in
Detroit Michigan we were traveling my
family and I few sons eventually would
be five sons and my mother and father
down from Detroit to visit our
grandparents in Georgia and Alabama we
stopped in Nashville Tennessee and my
mother took us into the restaurant and
we sat there this beautiful bright young
woman and her children and they said we
don't serve niggers here and my mother
didn't want to tell my father because
one of the most ignominious consequences
of the lethal and explosive reality of
race is that it often put black men in a
difficult position here you were on the
one hand responsible for taking care of
your family Society even through a
patriarchal lens viewed you as a
breadwinner and a participant in the
domestic shaping of one's family and yet
the means to achieve that were often
hobbled with bigotry that limited what
they could do and so she didn't want to
tell my father because she didn't want
to reinforce a sense of powerlessness
to a man who couldn't even get his
family a sandwich and something to drink
when he had the money to pay for
oriT because of the color of his skin
creating anger humiliation and thus my
mother absorbed the hit tried to protect
the psyche of her children and we
departed from that restaurant and now
less than 40 years later we have seen
the ascent of a man who as brother
Reeves has indicated despite the color
of his skin
despite the bigotry that may be
associated with other people who may
have that skin this man was embraced by
millions of people in this country and
by millions more around the globe Barack
Obama is an extraordinary man and we see
that extraordinary story reflected in so
many local narratives as I listen to
brother Reeves and his intelligent and
beautiful mother thinking about the
courage and the compassion of white
parents to adopt black children I know
that's controversial for some people
they say well we don't know if white
folks should be raised in black folk so
let's just leave him in the foster home
let's just leave them to their own
circumstances so they can be real black
and poor and struggling and oppressed as
opposed to being adopted by a loving
family who can raise obviously a
brilliant strong black man it does kill
a lot of the stories that you got to be
one thing to raise another thing right
black men in the embrace of a certain
patriarchal perspective though
undeniably cogent because of their
restriction to be able to nurture their
all in the demon
nation of black masculinity think that
well a black man only can raise a black
man they've been print plenty of sisters
who have raised strong black men in
America so we don't want to have a
biological determinism and a racial
determinism Steven Spielberg wants to
adopt black children Madonna rather be
poor weather in Africa or in Pittsburgh
we got to say thank God for some people
of conscience I wish I could get adopted
by Spielberg I was call them pops can I
spin around in the Porsche and go up on
the lights hang out a little bit and
kick it with my peeps this is a
beautiful kind of situation I don't deny
the complexities and complications of
what that might mean in terms of people
being able to foster and develop their
own children when the state intervenes
and negative fashion I get that and
completely comprehended but the broader
picture here of a family that was
compassionate in the mainstream opening
their house and heart to a young man
like brother Reeves and then listening
to sister Paul tell both with humor and
insight about the belief that the dream
was achieved and that we had overcome
it's awful honest of a young person to
admit that because a lot of young people
who have been benefited by the struggles
of people older than them don't
necessarily appreciate what the old
folks went through to get where they is
right those gramatical solace isms that
dot the linguistic landscape nonetheless
are the warehouse of profound wisdom and
so she admitted bless her heart
and so many others of us can't admit
that we thought it was said until we
came to Pittsburgh uh Philadelphia
Detroit or New York or in Appalachian
deep down into Delta and so many people
think because Barack Obama is President
we now live in a post-racial world well
first of all then and even a good idea
nor a good idea you see we don't want to
be post-racial post-racial assumes that
we have no constitutive elements to our
identities that are produced by the
positive reinforcement of self
affirmation so we don't have to give up
being black to the American white
brothers and sisters don't have to stop
being wait to be American in fact most
white brothers and sisters are never
asked about the contradiction between
their whiteness and their Americanists
because they've been collapsed with
black folk Latino folk Asian folk is the
opposite why how can you imagine being
the unified embodiment of American
identity and your particular racial
identity but see we don't want to be
post-racial I don't want to stop being a
brother this all I know how to be right
about now this this is it I can't learn
much of else of anything else and plus
it's pretty cool to be a brother right
about now
you know what I see Barack Obama and
forgive me I know it sounds perhaps
sacrilegious to you what that pimp
stroll I just I don't mean that in a
literal sense I'm not suggesting that
he's on the corner telling Mary and
Shaniqua to get that dough but that's
not what I'm talking about I'm talking
about a stylistic aesthetic of cold
then he greet in person right hand
brother pound on the back wassup right
and just the way he talks
they said that we couldn't make it
they said that we couldn't do it don't
don't don't hate the player
so don't eradicate the distinctive
elements of your identity in order to
placate a conception of race lessness
that is a myth to begin with and the
beauty of who we are is that we can all
come together e pluribus unum out of
many one you see if you give up being
who you is when you get up in the spot
you've negated the argument for you
being there in the first place the
reason we brought you in bra or sis is
cause you bring your particular flavor
with you
you see when when white brothers and
sisters come to hear Luther Vandross
they not coming to hear Frank Sinatra
and ain't no knock on the chairman of
the board fly me to the moon and let me
play among the stars he was a he was a
brilliant man but but but Luther was
something different
don't you remember I told you I loved
you baby baby baby baby whoo baby don't
give that up
we need Frank Sinatra we need that
brother to establish the metrics of the
American song to interpret the
brilliance of Berlin but we need sassy
saravana and Ella Fitzgerald too artists
get a tasket a brown and yellow basket
y'all don't know that about that but I'm
just y'all still stuck on little Wayne
and Weezy in them but that's so so it's
not either/or let's not eradicate Miles
Davis's trumpet so he can sound bland
and universal no we should not erase the
specific manifestation of the gifted
identities with which God has blessed us
we should not aim toward a post-racial
Society we should aim toward a post
racist society and what that means is
that we don't want to stop being who we
are we want you to stop having negative
viewpoints about who we are and that
means we all of us white black brown red
yellow across the rainbow Martin Luther
King jr. graduating at 15 from Morehouse
College because of the early entrance
for young students decimated and the
numbers depleted in war war two went to
college to study sociology would Walter
Chivers and then theological ethics with
George Kelsey and listening to the great
Benjamin Elijah Mays graduating at 19
going on to seminary
went to Boston College Boston University
excuse me to get a PhD in philosophical
theology comparing the theologies of
Nelson Wyman who was a personalist who
believed that God intervenes as a human
energy into the affairs of men and women
versus Paul Tillich who believed that
God was the ground of one's being not a
personal intervention in human history
but the fact of one's existence that's
what he was doing at 26 breaking that
off in a proper fashion so don't don't
be acting like that that that blackness
ain't about intelligence depends on what
strand of blackness you trying to pick
up see when folks say that there are
certain black people who say well
getting your lesson that's what my daddy
used to say getting your lesson that
means studying my daddy didn't say you
go you go you go you you you you gonna
engage in an act of pedagogical exchange
he said i'ma learn you a lesson no he
didn't say teach either he said learn
you a lesson is that epistemic
dissonance learn you a lesson you gonna
learn for me know what he was trying to
suggest it's more than that kind of in
felicitous turn of phrase it was a
deeply philosophical meditation upon the
nature of how knowledge invests the
teacher and the student in a reciprocal
expansion of knowledge and experience
and so learning a lesson is what black
is about when black folk talk about
active white that that ain't a whole
bunch of black folk because we want to
get rid of the notion that to talk a
certain way is to be black and to be
allergic to knowledge like you got to be
quarantined in ignorance no we know that
in a black thing we don't have eight
years
I don't know about you but brains are
back and it feels good it just is just
and both I'm went to Harvard so it ain't
about pedigree but but boy the one that
went to Harvard and the one that went to
Harvard
there's a difference so it can't be
Harvard got to be what to do with you
get to Harvard in a betting an argument
for the fact that that that what we must
do is sharpen our minds Martin Luther
King jr. was a student his entire life
and when he stood up when he was called
upon to be the leader of the Montgomery
Improvement Association he didn't have
but five minutes to get his speech
together if you ain't studied it ain't
gonna come out of you right then ain't
no such thing as Lord give me the words
to say did you study the words I might
can help you remember what you studied
but I can't give you nothing made up
this is like me going before the Nobel
Prize Committee in and mathematics
saying recognize my genius in
mathematics if I ain't studied
mathematics God is going to give me e
equals MC squared that ain't gonna
happen you got to study thermodynamics
and Brownian motion you got to go like
Einstein to a Bern Patent Office and you
got to dig deep into the to the
algorithm of the mathematical knowledge
of girdle and you got to figure out what
the world is about as a picture of
knowledge Einstein said imagination was
more important than knowledge because
ultimately physics was a poetic attempt
by scientific minds to trace the lineage
of the Divine Presence and so my
brothers and sisters studying hard is a
black thing
have an insight is a black thing
Frederick Douglass says learning unfits
a child for slavery because when you
learn something and you know what you
worth you will be unable to accept
second-class citizenship and so Martin
Luther King jr. fought against the
demons of white supremacy and social
injustice and ultimately economic
inequality and then of course he was not
very popular when he began to speak out
against the war in Vietnam many of you
young people may not know and older
people tend to forget that when King
died he was not a very popular man it's
easy to make up now like he was always
popular do you realize that by the time
he died for the first time in ten years
he had not made the Gallup polls list
for the ten most admired Americans do
you realize that Martin Luther King jr.
could hardly get an American University
to have him lecture do you realized that
Martin Luther King jr. didn't get put on
the Board of Trustees at his own alma
mater a historically black college
because the then white chairman of the
board of trustees brother Mero Marilyn
Lynch said that King was a poor role
model why because he went to jail too
often he went selling crack he was
trying to crack open the doors of
opportunity for all people and so Martin
Luther King jr. fought for the soul of
this nation he was not very popular he
wasn't just fighting for black folk he
was fighting for everybody
Martin Luther King jr. changed what
white Americans and Latino Americans and
Asian Americans and folks from all over
the goal the immigrants coming here to
seek the great American dream he made it
possible for all of them to speak a
different language and the vocabulary of
what was possible don't quarantine
Martin Luther King Junior's a great
black leader he was a great American
leader he's studied hard he was sharp
and intelligence he fought against the
forces that denies the opportunity to
enjoy as human beings but at the end of
his life when he spoke out against
economic inequality he said look when I
when I defended the civil rights bill I
had supported it didn't cost the nation
anything when we got Voting Rights Act
it didn't cost nation anything now this
will cost the nation because we're
talking about economic inequality and we
tell my why people are poor why white
poor people are inept election why poor
people of color and white brothers and
sisters down in the Delta
why folk who are working in automobile
factories now I've seen their resources
dry up and their wages be depleted King
was concerned he said about the empty
bellies of Americans poor of America's
poor children
he said we're getting rid of tons of
food a day I don't know where we can
store it in the bellies of those poor
kids who can't even eat every night give
education to them Martin Luther King jr.
opened up a Vista a grand horizon of
American democracy so that all human
beings could see what was possible when
we took democracy seriously see they
called him a non-american
called a man too patriotic ain't that
something the folk willing to die for
the nation shared their blood those upon
whose backs American possibility rest
when Barack Obama will be sworn in the
capital it was built by slave labor
the white house built by slave labor
these are not lazy and people who are
disinclined to work hard yet they could
not benefit from their labor from their
industrious work and yet they were never
tempted to lead the nation they did not
secede and yet brothers and sisters in
the south who were tired Oh
America because America wanted to
wrestle with slavery left America they
seceded and we never left that we are
taught on Americans because we want to
get treated right
it is a strange assignment this patriot
versus anti Patriot language that's why
I'm glad Barack Obama gonna be the
president let's get rid of the fact you
and I can disagree and we both Americans
and we love the nation right we might
not like your administration but we love
government your administration is messed
Dick Cheney my god is that a scary guy
or what Donald Rumsfeld
you ain't got no copyright on American
defense of practices and an
international landscape where your
cowboy
aesthetic and your politics of the
American juggernaut meet up against the
world community's disdain for America
they done made it hard to say you from
America where you from Jamaica but
you're blond blue haired in six-foot
four that's the right man
got the guns we're all black an American
now and so the restoration of the
dignity of America rests in the hand of
a man himself Barack Obama who was
called on America Sarah Palin says she
could see Russia from her backyard ain't
matter Sarah Palin's she doing her thing
call Barack Obama Palin around with
terrorists called him out American
called him a communist called him
everything but a child of God and yet
this man defended America's ideas to the
world and yet he was the great and most
eloquent language that we could have to
convince the rest of the world that we
were still invested in democracy that's
why the world community loves Barack
Obama 200,000 folk in Birdmen turn it
out to see a black man talk
that's what biggie said just to hear
biggie smalls speak right know y'all
went to see notorious don't interact it
was all a dream
used to read Word Up Magazine salt and
pepper Heavy D up in the limousine I
used to let my tape rock to my tape
then he said his mama you know we used
to fuss when the landlord dissed us no
heat wonder why Christmas birthdays were
the worst days now we sipped champagne
when we damn right I like the life I
live because I went from negative to
positive but you don't hear me though
and if you don't know now you know
excuse me old people that's just for the
young folk stereotypes of a black male
miss understood so Barack Obama commands
world attention because of his elegant
deportment his amazingly graceful
demeanor his embodiment of what it means
to be an American
it is not contradictory to suggest that
we are proud of him as a black man and
we are proud of him as an American you
know when his wife Michelle Obama made a
so-called gaffe and said this was the
first time she was proud they took a
stuff out of context then they put her
in witness protection program
now you mean to tell me you don't get
that if historically the nation has not
exactly lived up to the true meaning of
its Creed are you telling me as an
honest American you don't get it that if
people have spit upon you and water
hosed you because you simply wanted to
live like them in this memory of the
country you don't get why they wouldn't
necessarily celebrate the fourth of July
the same way still love the country
still go to foreign wars to defend it
and give their life for it but you want
us to be grateful to be treated as
second-class citizens don't you
understand that now when I sing America
it means something different because we
own a part of that now vicariously
through this man's ascent you don't get
that when we sing about the purple wave
of grain now it means something
different because now this man has
ascended as the president of everybody
that we have an extra sense of pride
that when we state the Pledge of
Allegiance it means something just a bit
different now our chests are more
heaving with pride my country tis of
thee sweet land of liberty of thee I
sing nothin a kind of narrow xenophobic
ethnocentric claim on Obama cuz he he
the black president he's the black
president that's different in the edge'
title descriptions we give to modify the
noun
he everybody president I know some black
folks off when Barack became president
they didn't have to pay taxes they don't
get Wesley snapped up in here don't
don't go I love you Wesley
some black folks felt oh my god we don't
have to go to jail no mo Negro Negro you
going to jail but what it does mean is
that now we have purchased on the
American Dream that we feel identified
with the nation in a special way and you
can understand that I have a sense of
proud of him as a black man I got to go
on Today Show tomorrow morning they know
Matt Lauer ago asked me is there
something special to me yes because my
mother's on the phone yesterday crying
71 years old because of incidents like
the one I told you about when she was a
little girl you gonna serve that little
nigga girl first before you serve me now
we're not holding any grudges because
Martin Luther King jr. taught us to love
everybody and we don't hate people and
despise people and I get angry at people
because of their race that would be to
buy into the very notions of
ethnocentrism that Martin Luther King
jr. spent his life against what it does
mean is that we should not live in a
post-racial society but a post racist
one we should not live in the United
States of amnesia and so Martin Luther
King jr. fought and bled and died he
mixed his blood with the soil there on a
desolate balcony and rainy Memphis where
he stood about to get his overcoat
because it was too chilly
Samuel Billy cows the minister in
Memphis waiting on him on the steps
Jesse Jackson down in the courtyard
Ralph Abernathy behind him about to
fetch the coat
andrew young hovering near dr. king
talking to Ben branch to play precious
Lord for me because he played with Jesse
Jackson's operation push band played
real pretty for me and then a rapport
ring out across the courtyard it found
its target with lethal accuracy there to
explode its message of death deep inside
of his neck the blood began to spill the
prophet's blood onto the pavement and
there ralph abernathy extracted a
cardboard from a laundered shirt and
scooped into a jar the blood of king
saying this is the blood of martin's
shed for us Jesse Jackson dipped his
hands into that blood and wiped them on
his shirt and appeared the next morning
on The Today Show Kings stains his blood
stained into Jackson's shirt a symbolic
passing of the mantle the blood of the
Prophet on his shirt and Jesse Jackson
to a special meeting of the City Council
and the mayor said that everybody who
stood against King and didn't do
everything they could have his blood on
their hands and so this unpopular
prophet I'm popular with white Americans
and many black Americans too and
posthumously many white Americans wanted
him clawless and many black Americans
wanted him flawless we want to take the
teeth out of King we freeze him before
mid nineteen sixty-three march on
Washington as if he ain't never gave
another speech as if he didn't say what
he believed he said later that year I
saw my dream turned into a nightmare
when four little girls were blown up in
Birmingham and all the streets of watts
where the language he
said a riot is the language of the
unheard when he saw the riots there
Martin Luther King jr. stood at the
sunlit summit of expectation and the
beauty of that speech the power of that
speech is magnificent but people missed
the most revolutionary part of it five
four years ago a great American in whose
symbolic shadow we stand today signed
the Emancipation Proclamation
they are Lincoln hovering over him and
then for anybody else it would have been
an a-plus speech but for Martin Luther
King jr. reading wasn't his thing not
reading a speech and they had no
teleprompters he read in the speech and
that's not him at his best so Mahalia
Jackson women were not allowed to speak
that day except they could sing
Mahalia Jackson a friend of the King
family because black women will find a
way regardless even if they don't
program their bodies ain't there their
voices will be there resonating in your
brain women of all stripes and colors
have learned in a sexist culture to
penetrate those patriarchal barriers
regardless of the stratagems of sexism
and so she said tell him about the Train
Martin King put the paper down and said
despite the difficulties of today and
tomorrow I still have a dream but he had
already announced that we are marooned
on a tiny island of poverty in the midst
of a vast ocean of material prosperity
he had already announced that the that
the that took that that the winds of
revolt would continue to shake the
foundations of America until the Negro
was granted his citizenship rights he'd
already talked about police brutality he
said that the Negroes in the south
couldn't vote in the Negroes in the
north believed they had nothing for
which to vote and then he came to that
part where mahalia said pick it up with
the spirit and so he got deep into
and he and he cast the paper aside from
the prodigious hilltops of New Hampshire
let freedom ring from the mighty
mountains of New York let freedom ring
from Lookout Mountain of Tennessee from
every Hill and molehill of Mississippi
from every mountainside he said one day
my four little children will live in a
nation where they will not be judged by
the color of their skin but by the
content of their character and he said
this will be the day when all of God's
children black men and white men Jews
and Gentiles Protestants and Catholics
will be able to join together in the
singing of that Negro spiritual free at
last free at last thank God Almighty we
are free at last but he gave an even
more powerful and poignant speech the
night before he died their king standing
in Memphis in a pulpit talking about
defending poor black workers the bushwa
Negro ministry wasn't necessarily
invested in defending poor folk they
didn't want to get their Cadillacs
stained and their churches messed up and
so King said that's not right you are
more interested he said a few weeks
before that a couple of months before
that in the wheelbase of your automobile
then you are and the poor people who
made it possible for you to get those
Cadillacs
if he was speaking now he just said
riding on 20's with the top down and so
King was critical of those black
ministers who refused to defend the
vulnerable and bourgeois black leaders
who were lambasted the poor without
attempting to help them we see that
played out today famous black
entertainers going around the country
beating up on poor folk dog an amount as
opposed to trying to help them as if you
berating them in public is gonna help
them and how arrogant and hypocritical
because
many of the families of poor people do
far better morally than folk with a
bunch of money and some of the people
doing the instructing would would do
well to take a hard look in the mirror
that's why you got to be very careful
when you use a bully pulpit as a way to
chide the vulnerable Martin Luther King
jr. said we must be concerned about them
he said the black middle-class has
forgotten what it means to have the foul
stench and odour of social suffering in
their own nostrils because they left the
side stream and got involved in the
mainstream but he said God calls us to
our awareness of those who are poor and
so at the end of his life he defended
the vulnerable and he stood that night
with those sanitation workers from
Memphis who were trying to get fair
wages and King said if we don't treat
them right we treat nobody ray and as
you heard sister hall talk about this
extraordinary last speech King gave when
he said America be true to what you said
on paper if you said it live it I love
this country enough to tell it the truth
and then an assassin's bullet failed him
Martin Luther King jr. went instantly
from a pariah to a profit from a man who
was unpopular to the most popular figure
one could imagine now he's got a
birthday celebration in his name 40
years after his assassination we're
about to experience an inauguration the
distance from King's assassination to
Obama's inauguration is a quantum leap
of faith that neither cynics nor
boosters could predict 40 years later
this brilliant young man standing with
the confidence that he could be
President even when most black folk
didn't believe it I didn't say white
brothers and sisters I said bless black
folk
not with Obama at the beginning I know I
was there I looked around me and several
white people were saying yes we can
write don't act like he was there you
know now you can't find a person that
didn't March with dr. King who's black
or a white brother and sister who didn't
love him
so black folk we are marks with dr. King
back in 1915 now he wasn't born in 1929
but don't let that stop you
it's amazing me not in if you hear any
criticism of Obama black folk get crazy
oh no you didn't talk about Jesus now
where was this belief in Obama when he
started black leadership class the raid
against him told him wait his turn you
ain't ready yet said some funky stuff
about the brother he kept on going black
leadership class said you you have
jumped skipped and you have leapfrogged
over a bunch of folk in lying as if
that's how leadership was distributed as
if charisma and competence and ability
rest upon what you can distribute if
ever it is proved that God don't need
your permission to put in place who the
almighty would and forgive that
reference to the divine in the secular
institution whether you believe the
forces of destiny are controlled by mere
human beings you can't determine what's
gonna happen neither with King older
leadership didn't like him Roy Wilkins
from the n-double-a-cp
said are you
actually going into the streets how
undignified we must fight this battle on
the sweets and in the courts and so
older black leadership thought Kings
direct nonviolent action of the streets
was dangerous as miss Hall recited to
you King understanding that ball Conor
not only didn't understand history and
didn't read it but King understood he
could manipulate Bull Connor and Bull
Connor Unleashed those water hoses and
those horses and bicuspids and incisors
of police dogs ripping the vulnerable
flesh of children and women he made many
white Americans uncomfortable who were
trying to eat their dinners while
watching the television full of this
chaos King was a brilliant dramaturges
he was a thespian of the first order he
had a sense of the dramatic and so he
orchestrated the public presentation of
black suffering that would appeal to
white Americans across the country and
to members of the world community around
the globe
older older leaders were hating on him
at the march on Washington they they
they jockey to be first because CBS was
gonna be the only cameras there that day
and they knew they were only gonna be on
for a little while let me speak first
thing why the cameras on so they said
they don't put King last plus we ain't
going after him and a strange thing
happened they pushed King glass and
instead of CBS leaving ABC and NBC
joined them so you might admit it for
evil but God meant it for good so now
not only does King F CBS by the time
he's supposed to speak supposed speak
for about he gave him eight minutes he
took nineteen the left we hope of mr.
Obama's speech as it freezes tomorrow
King took 19 minutes and transformed the
world the jangling discords of our
society into a beautiful
symphony of brotherhood he took 19
minutes and he inscribed into the
collective imagination of America the
bold strokes of democracy but there are
other folk were hating on him now those
same motor folk who stood with King rod
all the folk hated on him hated on Obama
too young don't know what you doin you
ain't really black enough
Bill Clinton blacker than you he didn't
have most sisters than you now that
might be true brother Bill going to the
church he knew the hems and the hemlines
I don't write the news I'm just
recording history thank you Bill Clinton
didn't need no paper for the third verse
I saw y'all look around stony the glove
god of god of our weary is in a verse
Bill Clinton saying it by heart god of
our weary years god of our silent it's
comin equals God who s led us thus black
folk said I think he making that up that
a real night King died and got murdered
he was a student at Georgetown he was
reciting by heart day I have a dream
speech deep I'm almost done deeply
involved in black culture in history but
because he got so close he could also be
so exploitative he signed a crime bill
and welfare reform that devastated
millions that crime bill made the
disparity between crack and powder
cocaine a law and put people in the jail
for $25 vials of crack
but he took $10,000 of an offense for
powdered cocaine to get the same
sentence they said he gotta wait his
turn
you ain't black enough and what does
that mean because his mama was white and
his daddy was black African to be exact
now you can look at me to see that the
tradition of edifying intermarriage
intermingling and sexual escapades
across the axes of rigid epidermis
fetish has always existed I mean if you
shake the genetic tree of mow black folk
Italians Irish Polish Jews lit the wing
is native Amer because because people
love chocolate this true
you got your peanut butter in my
chocolate I got my chocolate in your
peanut butter
how they berries mama was white told
Halle Berry but in America you a black
woman don't ever forget it
there have been so many interesting
alliances of race that have challenged
the narrow bigotry on all sides and so
cause his mama was white in Kansas and
his daddy was African from Kenya and
black folk said he wasn't black enough
let me get this straight his daddy's
from Africa that's not on a South Side
of Chicago
Kenny ain't that a suburb of Texas no
bruh that's on the continent herding
goats that's all some African tip and he
ain't black enough and you from Georgia
it teaches the Nation about different
follicle constituencies follicular
comparisons are unavoidable we don't
have to deny that to say but therefore
all of America he wasn't black enough
they put him down he gotta wait his time
it's not time yet you can't tell nobody
when the people are claiming him that it
ain't time the people demanded that he
run and then when he signed up most of
the black leadership was against him and
then he won Iowa black folk said you
know a neighbor folk Negroes in Iowa
that's
I don't even know if they got a Kentucky
Fried Chicken and I and so black folks
start telling you hey baby that that
that that boy one that what yeah yeah
Barrack Obama we got to get with him got
to give him a chance because black folk
don't never vote for you just cause you
black despite what people tell you we
don't do that Clarence Thomas run he
gonna get fo votes three from his people
and he gonna vote for himself my point
is as I take my seat my brothers and
sisters Barack Obama won the
old-fashioned way cuz he told America he
had a better vision that's why he didn't
get obsessed with race he wasn't trying
to make it about vote for me cuz I'm a
black man
vote for me cuz I'm the best candidate
running and black folk at our best I've
always understood that that's all we
were X info give us the chance to prove
we got the goods do you think Jackie
Robinson was the first ballplayer who
could have played professional sports as
a baseball player Babe Ruth hit 714 home
runs brother Josh hit 899 major leagues
it wasn't major two brothers get
involved when you tie the arms of
participants behind their backs with the
rope of bigotry you do not have the
greatest until you let everybody
participate equally that's right now
baseball is basically a lot B no affair
with some white guys and some brothers
don't even forget mission and now what
Obama being president could be
basketball could take over as the
national pastime hoops will become a
national obsession so what's interesting
it seems to me is that is that when we
understand that all we've ever wanted
was to show America we could be good for
everybody not just for ourselves when
people say you have to stop being black
to be accepted to Roberta Flack ain't
gotta stop being black for white
brothers and sisters understand killing
me softly with his killing me softly
with his right speaking about I think
Don McLean and so Sarah Vaughn Toni
Morrison they don't have to stop being
who they are in doing what they do to be
accepted Barack Obama is a black man but
he's not only for black people he's
rooted in but not restricted by his
blackness three different forms of
blackness accidental incidental and
intentional accident I'm an American I
just happened to be a Negro oh okay
incidental I'm rooted in but not
restricted by my blackness Barack Obama
roots should nurture they should not
strangle and Barack Obama said I will
draw from that blackness but it will not
exhaust my universe I'm proud of what I
am but all that I am is that exhausted
by that description of that adjective
before that none of my personhood and
then you got intentionally black I'm
black that's what I do that's what I've
been doing that's what I know that's who
I is
now depending on where you are black
people do all three of those if you
before the Supreme Court you make an
argument to defend affirmative action
you're intentionally black if you at the
company picnic
right well let's just say this if you
down in South Carolina like of Barack
Obama and you want to communicate to
black people in South Carolina I feel
your pain I love you I know you I'm
rooted in you but I got to speak to
everybody you signified what did Barack
Obama do in that speech three days
before he won the primary he asked black
people do you know you've been
bamboozled you've had to okeydoke y'all
know what the okey-doke is yeah they
laughed he said you been bamboozled you
been hoodwinked
you've been tucked who was he quoting
but he went gonna say it I'm quoting
Malcolm X from Spike Lee's movie that
would have gone over like a brick cloud
I have fallen and whiteness and can't
speak up Barack Obama understood that he
had his eye on the prize but he wanted
to let black folk know so he signified
I'm with you but don't act like you
don't understand I got to do this thing
in such a fashion that everybody feels
that they participate in my dream but
I'm gonna throw you a rhetorical bone by
signifying that I understand where
you're coming from I know how to speak
the language and I can top that talk
that's incidental blackness my accent Oh
black this is when you go to the company
picnic and you want to raise
you take your blackness to the to the to
the to the gate you said now look you
stay right here I'm gonna be right back
don't go home with nobody just stay
right here you going hi how would you
know fine how are you
by jiminy Christmas did you see that
Doris Day movie last night it's amazing
que sera sera whatever will be will be
the futures lobbed it Rockets an
interesting guy I have to race Thanks
see you tomorrow bye have some that
apple pie left you see you all right
come on blackness look you got a raise
too we both got to eat and so all I'm
saying my brothers and sisters is that
Barack Obama challenges narrow
narratives murderous myths of racial
authenticity from within blackness and
he challenges America to accept the fact
that it is the content of your character
and not the color of your skin and at
the same time we can be all that we were
meant to be by the god or the force of
the universe that created us and as I
take my seat when I think about King and
Obama stenciled or steamed on two
t-shirts they ain't the same person
neither should they be ones of
politician the other is a prophet they
got different jobs y'all don't expect
Barack Obama to be Martin Luther King
jr. he can't do it that's not his job
description that's not what the
presidency is called for it calls for
him to adjudicate competing claims about
resource distribution we must make
arguments that are valid and legitimate
as African American people on the
commonweal but do so with a eye toward
making the entire society better even as
we argue for our particular group all
groups should be created and recognized
equally so Barack Obama's job as
president is to do that to use the
American presidency as a bully pulpit to
make the nation greater now that doesn't
mean he has to ignore his blackness or
the claim
of people who look like him who made it
possible for him to become what he is
black Phil sometimes get this twisted
they think that if he criticized Barack
Obama
it's a sacrilegious events you must hold
him high in esteem you must hold him in
prayer and you must hold him accountable
if he don't do what he said he gon do
you don't give him no slip you don't
give him no slack because he's a brother
if you'd messed up doing what you said
you was gonna do you don't get our vote
I don't care what color you are because
he's asked not to be treated based upon
his color so don't you appeal to
tribalism to excuse the necessity for
you to hold him accountable now Barack
Obama when asked by Wolf Blitzer tell us
why Martin Luther King jr. would support
your candidacy he said he wouldn't none
of us would he support he would get
America to hold us accountable why would
you deny Obama being held accountable
when he himself has envisioned his
presidency being held accountable and so
my brothers and sisters I say to you
that Barack Obama is a President and
Martin Luther King jr. is a prophet
prophets make presidents uncomfortable
Jesse Jackson and Al Sharpton ain't lost
no job because Barack Obama is employed
that's one brother in public housing on
1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
those are some great digs mind you but
we must not be seduced by the notion
that while Obama is in the White House
brother asked in Oakland shot in his
back for the Grimes on New Year's Day in
New Orleans but a hail of 40 bullets and
so it's Obama and Oscar
it's those over incarcerated black males
who through no fault of their own who
don't deserve to be thrown away because
they made a mistake and it is their
appreciation for the fact that the
nation has made an enormous leap forward
with Barack Obama's presidency that we
all should be proud of but profits
sometimes do difficult things like
criticize politicians and we must have
both and
not either/or we need prophets and
politicians when most black folk heard
what Jeremiah Wright said they weren't
surprised most black folk initially said
now tell many part of Jeremiah Wright's
speech that was messed up I'm just
trying to get it I'm just trying to I'm
trying to get the part he was wrong on
of course you don't have to greet it
aids is created to hurt black people but
a lot of people do the most famous
person who put that notion forward about
11 years ago was Bill Cosby
so it ain't just poor black folk with
paranoia and conspiracy who believe that
I don't believe that but I understand
the skepticism of science not not
science but scientists we ain't afraid
to science we afraid of scientists not
technology but technicians so my point
simply is when Jeremiah Wright's
prophetic urge
regardless of whether you agree with him
or not his argument was rooted in the
fact that we must criticize a nation
that is gone astray that's not a
president's job he is to protect the
Union he is to preserve and provide
through his oaths the common will of
America to be united Benjamin Franklin
said we must hold it together Thomas
Jefferson said we must unite it Barack
Obama is in that tradition of Lincoln
most especially not King but Kings
tradition must live to Kings tradition
of prophetic expression must live on
because we must hold Pharaoh accountable
we gonna have some cognitive dissonance
because now Moses has yielded to Pharaoh
David is now Goliath and once since
Barack Obama is the man and the man
that's a beautiful dilemma to have and
as I take my seat then he is the
president not a prophet but King is a
prophet who must speak to presidents and
politicians we need both of them and so
as I take my seat I will sign books and
then take to the air and go back to
Washington DC I'ma be on The Today Show
and then I'm making my way to the mall
not to buy an iPod the one in Washington
DC where I'm going to see her brother
stride up on stage
Bruce Roberts who can't even imagine the
world from which Barack Obama comes has
to administer the oath of office to her
brother
they called him a terrorist they called
him a communist they cardamon Marxist
but tomorrow they're gonna call him
President of the United States
that's the embodiment of the brain
please